difficile de croire qu'à cet endroit il
y avait un hôtel l'un des plus luxueux
de la caraïbe c'était dans les années 80
90 c'est ici qu'ils étaient le méridien
à la pointe du bout aux trois ilets
cela fait quelques années que sa
reconstruction est annoncée aucun projet
à l'horizon
quelques danses plus loin un autre hôtel
a fermé en 2014
les murs sont toujours là en l'état en
revanche le club alain salas ne reçoit
plus de client
mais pourquoi ces hôtels n'étaient reste
il pas les investisseurs
on ne réussit pas à trouver des
investisseurs parce que le modèle
économique de l'hôtellerie martiniquaise
est pas très vertueux c'est à dire que
nos charges sont trop importantes on a
des taux de remplissage comme un peu on
a quelques points de retard par rapport
à aux îles avoisinantes mais on n'est
pas mauvais pas pour la métropole
par contre les charges d'exploitation
notamment la masse salariale le coût des
achats faits qu'on dégage pas
suffisamment de profits pour
l'investisseur qui lui vaut un retour
sur investissement rapide
pas assez rentable c'est là semble-t-il
le problème de nos hôtels
autre exemple cet espace que vous
connaissez peut être cité le diamant ne
rock
les travaux de reconstruction aurait dû
débuter toujours pas de travaux en dix
ans la martinique a perdu environ 1400
chambres d'hôtel pourtant le nombre de
touristes ne cessent d'augmenter
c'est juste liée à une un modèle
économique lac est différent pour les
familles c'est moins onéreux que de fins
de prendre un appartement ou une petite
villa ou alors une grosse villa
que d'aller en inde allait prendre
plusieurs chambres d'hôtel qui sont plus
onéreux c'est sûr la solution ce serait
quoi
ce serait un des hôtels un peu mixte à
la fois avec une partie hôtelière pur et
dur et puis résidences hôtelières aux
côtés 67 hôtel pour 3400 chambre c'est
ce qui nous reste dans notre parc
hôtelier le dernier établissement à
avoir fermé c'était le marouba en 2015
au carbet la fin de cette histoire une
vente aux enchères pour tous soldés
pour l'heure trois sites attentes des
repreneurs notre modèle touristique ne
permettrait-il pas la présence de plus
d'hôtels en martinique
en tout cas il semblerait qu'il faille
leur pensée et reconstruire différemment